hey folks this is International master
David proofs from chess comm with a
video that will tell you everything you
need to know to play the Kings gambit
now first off who is the Kings gambit
for the Kings gambit is for you because
you don't like playing boring chess the
Kings gambit is for people who are
confident and people who are good at
complicated and tactical positions so
here is what the Kings gambit is after a
you figure you know Knight f3 knight c6
bor-ring so you play f4 and you
sacrifice your pond so black can take it
and then you'd be down upon they'd also
be threatening Queen h4 check now what
is the point of the Kings gambit well
there are three things that you play for
in the opening and chess one is
development two is control of the center
and the third is long-term advantages
like being up material having more space
having weak pawn structure for your
opponent in the Kings gambit you tend to
emphasize central control it's important
to know what you have and what you don't
have we didn't develop a piece when we
played f4 but we did attack black center
pawn and now we've diverted it from the
center so now white strategy is going to
be to dominate the center that's
strategy number one strategy number two
is to try and win back the pawn on f4 if
we can because actually it's pretty
annoying on the Kings side and strategy
number three if black defends this pawn
with moves like h6 and g5 then we're
going to get a development lead also
always remember to keep the game
complicated folks so for example Knight
f3 d6 d4 if your opponent just develops
a random piece you need to grab that
pawn don't think too long about this you
need that pawn but if your opponent
defends that pawn I want you to start
developing your pieces if they keep
making pawn moves defending those that
pawn chain you should keep getting your
pieces out and you should try to get a
development late and then attack your
opponent now there are two other
variations you need to know to play the
King's gambit one is by playing d5 the
most aggressive response you're going to
take that pawn because it's in the
center
he's going to play you for now you're
going to challenge that pawn because
it's in the center and when he plays
here you're just going to keep taking
stuff in the center even though your
opponent gets well ahead and development
like this you are going to take
everything in the center and then try
and fight for and defend that central
position be very careful with your king
there okay
the final variation that you need to
know is the black could just defend the
pawn with d6 or the better move Bishop
to c5 preventing you from castling don't
ever fall for a really really painful
Queen h4 check instead you need to bring
your knight step 3 as soon as possible
to stop that black will defend and now
in keeping with the Kings gambit what do
you do you play c3 and then you push d4
taking over the center remember are you
developing quickly here no is he quite
likely yes right he might bring out a
knight here you play d4 he trades and
comes here so now your goal is you need
to defend your center pawns because you
are behind in development do that and
you will dominate later that's all you
need to know about the King's gambit for
now I hope you enjoyed this video and
I'll see you around on chess calm